now tonight the crisis at our Southern
border is a top issue for American
voters and now after lying you know to
our face the bord secure the borders
closed for three plus years and
pretending that that border was actually
secure while Joe Biden is actually
trying a new tactic we have it on tape
take a look do you believe that that the
border
is no it's not I haven't belied it for
the last 10 years and I've said it for
the last 10 years give me the money
oh all of a sudden according to Joe the
Border hasn't been secure for a decade
uh since he was vice president uh but
it's just not his fault he wants you to
believe there's nothing he can do by the
way there's plenty that he can do he
doesn't need Congress he inherited
secure borders and yet he wants you to
forget about all those executive orders
that he signed making it easier to cross
the border illegally or all the aiding
and ab betting that he's been involved
in with the illegal immigrants and all
the money that has been spent by the
federal government by States uh to pay
for housing and health care and
education etc for people that didn't
respect our laws Borders or sovereignty
he also wants you to ignore his battle
with the state of Texas while the Lone
Star State attempts to fortify and
secure their borders do the job the
federal government has failed to do the
Biden Administration they actually sued
Texas took them all the way to the
Supreme Court to stop the state from
actually doing their job and today well
mission accomplished for Joe Biden 54
decision the US Supreme Court ruled that
the federal government can cut down
razor wire and other uh barriers to free
up illegal entry for now here to respond
Texas Senator Ted Cruz Senator you're a
constitutional scholar I am shocked at
the Chief Justice and Amy Cony Barrett
and and them going along with the
liberal minority here the federal
government has been aiding and edding
law breaking Joe Biden has not upheld
his his oath to our constitution to
enforce the laws of our land uh what
else does Texas have available to them
if they won't do the job they got to do
it
themselves well Sean that's exactly
right and listen this decision makes me
angry and and and even more Angry is
listening to Joe Biden just flat out lie
and he knows he's lying although
actually give it his mental condition
maybe he doesn't know he's lying but
anyone rational that was aware of the
world around him would know that he was
lying he says the boorder hadn't been
secure for 10 years and just give me the
money well you know what when Joe Biden
became president three years ago he
inherited the lowest rate of illegal
immigration in 45 years we had made
incredible progress securing the border
and Joe Biden deliberately
systematically dismantled it and if you
look at the numbers we went from the
lowest rate in 45 years to right now
today the highest rate of illegal
immigration in history ever 9.6 million
illegal immigrants have come in at Joe
Biden and here's the thing to understand
he's not unhappy about that he doesn't
want to solve it he doesn't want to
prevent it he wants more it was a
deliberate decision and when he asked
for more money it's not more money to
build a wall it's not more money to
secure the Border he wants more money to
process illegal immigrants faster to
move even more of them into every city
in America he wants to take that 9.6
million and make it 20 million make it
30 million make it 40 million it is an
in Invasion and Texas is bearing the
brunt but every community in America is
paying the price you you went the
longest in terms of any one candidate
back in 2016 against Donald Trump uh I
believe it ended after Indiana you had
won Wisconsin if my me memory serves me
properly um it was you went further than
anybody you see what's happening here
you see these latest poll numbers out of
New Hampshire I'd be shocked to believe
that all of these polls that have Trump
up by you know 18 19 20 plus points are
going to be that far off uh maybe he'll
win by five points but it still would be
a big victory for him what happens after
that would Nikki Haley risk going into
her home state where she's down 30
points and losing her home state look I
I I think this race is over last week on
your show I endorsed Donald Trump and
the reason I endorse Donald Trump is I
think he's won the Primary the results
in Iowa were overwhelming I stayed out
of it to let the voters speak you look
at what happened in Iowa he won over
over 51% of the vote he won 98 out of 99
counties that is overwhelming that is a
powerful outcome going to New Hampshire
New Hampshire tomorrow look Haley is
close to Trump in New Hampshire it's
possible that Haley will be close it's
even possible that she wins in New
Hampshire particularly because New
Hampshire allows Independents to vote in
the primary so about a third of the
state are Independents they can show up
tomorrow and on that day they can decide
do I want want to vote Democrat do I
want to vote Republican the Boston Globe
this weekend wrote an editorial urging
every independent don't vote in the
Democrat primary vote in the Republican
primary to beat Donald Trump they said
we don't like Nikki Haley but we hate
Donald Trump so there's a chance Nikki
Haley wins tomorrow but whether she does
or not frankly doesn't matter because
after that it goes to South Carolina I
think Nikki Haley will stick around to
South Carolina and she is going to lose
her home state by double digits and
after that is super Tuesday where she's
down by huge margins everywhere I think
this race is over and so I hope we see
the Republican Party come together UniFi
to beat Joe Biden because the results of
this Administration have frankly been a
train wreck and a disaster for the
country we're going to get to the
president he's now taking the stage very
quickly how do you explain what I call
this Trump phenomenon that he defies all
conventional political Gravity the the
the qu the the the old rules of politics
obviously don't apply to him if he's
arrested you know after all that he's
been through people now see this as as a
persecution not prosecution yes um is
they have they just overreached now for
the last seven years and this is the
result of it well listen number one
Trump has has enormous backbone he's got
guts he stands up and fights but number
two he broke the Democrat Party he broke
the media they hate him and and so look
I I I eny en the conversation between
you and Newton and Newton was right had
there been one case maybe it would have
gone somewhere but this is so obviously
a persecution that people are tired of
seeing the government weaponized that's
a big part of why Trump is winning this
primary
decisively all right Senator Ted Cruz uh
we appreciate it uh any thought that
maybe in four years you might jump back
in
yourself well look I've got a race this
year I'm running for reelection in Texas
Chuck Schumer has made me his number one
Target in the country and so please come
to tedcruz.org make a contribution the
Democrats are going to spend $100
million trying to beat me so go to tedc
cru.org I need your help and I I'll give
you my word I'm going to stand and fight
alongside Donald Trump to turn this
country around and bring us back from
the mess Joe Biden has given us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else